mais d'abord les enseignements de notre
baromètre d'octobre avec cécile 6 ou
à quelques mois de la présidentielle la
popularité des manuels macron remonte
avec quatre points de plus par rapport
au mois dernier il est pour 44% et
france est un bon président d'après le
sondage son allocution du 9 novembre à
booster sa visibilité et celle du
gouvernement son premier ministre
notamment semble en profiter jean castex
passe de 37% d'opinions favorables à 41%
chez les candidats aient l'air et xavier
bertrand passe de 27 à 28% d'opinions
favorables il est toujours placé devant
ses concurrents valérie pécresse à 24%
qui progresse également d'un point et
michel barnier qui stagne ne lui à 22%
le sondage montre en revanche un
essoufflement du côté d'eric zemmour le
polémiste perd deux points de popularité
ce mois ci un recul qui confirme qu'à
l'extrême droite les français font plus
confiance à la candidate fn marine le
pen elle serait en effet plus capable de
diriger la france pour 27% des français
contre 13% pour eric zemmour enfin à
gauche pas d'évolution pour un hidalgo
avec 18 pour son adhésion des français
mais elle perd tout de même lui terrain
auprès de ses sympathisants
avec cinq points de moins ce mois ci les
leçons de novembre chaque mois avec
notre partenaire au doxa mascaret on
vous donne on vous détaille les
résultats de ce baromètre est donc gaël
sliman le président de l'institut ad'hoc
ça et évidemment à mes côtés bonsoir
bienvenue avec sager bonsoir vous êtes
avocate présidente du think tank france
audacieuse face à vous pablo qui oblige
un bon soir responsable éditorial de la
revue regards et lætitia cru pas
éditorialiste politique est à mes côtés
bonsoir laetitia bienvenus évidemment à
vous aussi peut-être gaël un un premier
balayage on va dire un peu un peu
général des des enseignements de ce de
ce baromètre de novembre oui on peut
dire alors ça déjà été bien bien résumée
à l'instant mais si on si on veut faire
un petit pitch on peut dire trois
éléments clés alors que nous sommes à
cinq mois de l'élection présidentielle
1 on un président de la république nous
sommes en france qui a des niveaux de
popularité inégalée par rapport à chacun
de ses prédécesseurs à cinq mois d'une
éventuelle réélection savent pas dire
qu'il a déjà gagné la présidentielle
emmanuel macron loin de là enfin pour le
moment le ciel est bien dégagé pour lui
je précise nous sommes en france parce
qu'il est à 44% d'opinions positives en
l'occurrence de français qui nous dise
qu'il est un bon président ça veut dire
quand même on a une majorité de français
qui estiment qu'il est un mauvais
président mais nous sommes en france
c'est beaucoup mieux que tous ses
prédécesseurs et notamment les deux
derniers c'est plus de deux fois plus
que françois hollande c'est 10 points de
plus que nicolas sarkozy a à pareille
époque et puis le ciel est bien dégagé
pour lui aussi parce que quand on
regarde notre code d'adhésion et du
rejet des personnalités politiques on en
test 25 on voit que ya pas vraiment de
concurrent sérieux ou dangereux qui pour
le moment parvient à émerger la plupart
des personnalités bien classée dans le
classement sont des ministres de son
gouvernement où
dieu au lieu de l'opinion actuellement
edouard philippe son ancien premier
ministre et puis donc à ce duel et puis
à ce duel
il ya de ce duel d'image on pourra en
parler longuement je pense mais c'est
très intéressant parce qu'on a vraiment
passé au crible les deux candidats
d'extrême droite et on se rend compte
que pour s'était dit pour le moment eric
zemmour ne fait pas le poids dans
l'opinion face à marine le pen ni auprès
de l'ensemble des français ni auprès des
sympathisants et rennes à la limite vous
me direz c'est normal mais même pas
auprès des sympathisants aient l'air et
ça ça risque d'être compliqué du coup
pour eric zemmour parce qu'il faut qu'il
arrive à redresser la barre sur tous les
critères d'image il est jugé pire
qu'elle je dis pas meilleur parce que
les gens sont toujours très critique
avec marine le pen mais grâce à eric
zemmour bah finalement on a l'impression
d'une marine le pen dans l'image
s'adoucit un peu alors que le pic
l'opinion est très sévère avec eric
zemmour allez on va détailler tout ça
est d'abord autour de la popularité des
manuels macron cette question estelle
solide avec donc ce cette réponse
emmanuel macron est il un bon président
oui à 44% et vous l'avez évoqué si on
compare cette popularité à cinq mois de
l'élection françois hollande était à 16%
nicolas sarkozy à 37% comment vous
l'analysez cette popularité avec saint
germain je crois qu'il ya eu les prises
des paroles de parole successives du
président qui à chaque fois il s'est
très bien manoeuvré cela que ça soit au
mois de juillet où que ce soit au mois
de novembre il y avait évidemment le
boost du point de vue sanitaire mais il
y avait également le la
présidentialisation qui revenait de
l'avant et qui mettait le président en
situation de pré campagne sans toutefois
l'annoncer mais ça c'est quelque chose à
chaud on voit bien qu'à chaque fois
qu'il ya des prises de parole il gagne
des points donc
c'est une
c'est quand même quelque chose qui qui
montre la stature du président portant
également à l'étranger il y à des
secousses et c'était un an de voir mais
on sait bien qu'en matière
présidentielle ce qui se passe à
l'étranger peut être un plus au moment
où on dit il y a une stature d'homme
d'état mais n'intéresse pas beaucoup et
n'influence pas beaucoup sur le sur les
cotes de popularité
vous avez parlé de solidité si on se
projette il y a encore cinq mois il y a
quand même eu nous voilà il ya quand
même beaucoup de temps et il y a quand
même une zone de danger qui est à la
fois sur le sanitaire mais également sur
le régalien parce que on voit bien que
sur le sanitaire la situation est quand
même sur un fil et il faut espérer que
même si on est en bonne bonne position
il y a néanmoins des semaines qui vont
être compliqués autour déchéance qui
sont traditionnellement chéri par les
français à juste titre qu'ils sont les
fêtes de noël etc et donc si on voit une
tension et et ne serais sans aller
jusqu'à une idée de confinement mais ne
serait-ce que l'idée de remettre
éventuellement du télétravail en place
obligatoire ou des dés
des renforcements du passani terre on
sait que ça ce sont les sujets qui vont
revenir dans la campagne et le régalien
parce que ce qui se passe en guadeloupe
aujourd'hui ce n'est que le début d'un
feuilleton qu'on espère le plus court
possible mais qui peut avoir néanmoins d
impact sur la façon dont celle et l erp
notamment pour la partie de l'électorat
et l'eire qui est hanté par un vote
macron on sait très bien que ce sont des
questions qui sont très importantes pour
le choix dans l'isoloir et si on analyse
la popularité des manuels macron des
deux côtés droite et gauche chez les
sympathisants de gauche or elle est fine
et à 40 % chez les sympathisants et
l'air il est à 43 % pablo pino vivien
est ce que quand on regarde cet
équilibre finalement doigt de gauche
est-ce qu'ils s'expliquent pas aussi par
la faiblesse de la gauche si je pense
que c'est une évidence mais pour
compléter compléter ce qui vient d'être
dit je pense que ce que paient emmanuel
macron c'est avant tout sans sa
politique sanitaire en fait les français
sont contents en fait de ce qu'il a fait
d'un point de vue sanitaire ils sont
contents d'eux des différents
confinement ils sont contents du quoi
qu'il en coûte ils ont leur avait prédit
n'en déplaise d'ailleurs à tous les
opposants de gauche comme de droite à
emmanuel macron on avait l'impression
qu'en septembre il y allait avoir des
des faillites que la france allait être
à feu et à sang après après le coc vide
bah ça n'a pas été le cas les
entreprises continuent de fonctionner il
ya eu des licenciements mais finalement
ça a été relativement contenu donc en
soi même des records en matière de
d'emplois exactement exactement
exactement même s'il ya des gens qui
souffrent un même s'il ya des gens qui
continuent à aller chercher de l'aide
alimentaire et que le secours populaire
continue d'alerter
globalement je pense que vous avez bah
voila c'est 45 % de français qui
considèrent que emmanuel macron fait du
bon boulot et je pense que c'est
d'ailleurs vous m'interrogez sur la
gauche je pense que c'est d'ailleurs une
erreur de la part de toute la gauche en
général en fait c'est de considérer que
emmanuel macron il est détesté par les
gens et en fait on parle de 7,7 de cette
proposition là on se dit de cette
hypothèse là on se dit emmanuel macron
et des tests par les gens du goût qu'est
ce qu'on va proposer moi je pense qu'il
faudrait plutôt analyser quand on est
dedans quand on est à gauche on devrait
plutôt se dire en fait la proposition d'
emmanuel macron elle plaît et elle plaît
d'autant plus que ce qu'il propose pour
l'avenir ce qu'ils proposent ce que là
il est quand même à moitié rentrer en
campagne avec sa dernière allocution
présidentielle ça ressemblait plus à un
discours de campagne car un discours
strictement sur la politique sanitaire
en fait ce qu'il propose les gens sont
honnêtes on adhésion avec ce qu'ils
proposent notamment sur sa technophilie
propose une france qui rêve d'une france
technologique etc et je pense que la
gauche est là il ya un énorme déficit à
cet endroit parce qu'elle n'arrive pas
en fait à proposer un lendemain qui
chante et et puis c'est vrai aussi
laetitia quand on voit vous parliez des
prises de parole il ya à chaque fois
enfin son ex scores d'audience qui sont
très très élevé donc c'est aussi une
tribune fin il ya autour de la situation
sanitaire en espèces de ne sais pas quel
terme employer mais une cape qui
entourent emmanuel macron qu'il protège
peut-être des attaques quand il est dans
cette posture là forcément ça le sert
dans l'opinion oui bien sûr il habitait
puisqu'il touche énormément de cible
d'un seul groupe il a battu le record
historique de l'allocution
présidentielle sous la vème république à
la télévision donc à partir de là oui
bien sûr et gardera cette couronne là et
il le sait c'est théorisé dans son
équipe c'est à dire que il faut occuper
n'importe quel espace donc un espace
télévisée bien sûr puisque ça reste
encore un média de masse mais n'importe
quel espace c'est pour ça qu'il va sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est pour ça que il
fait aussi les micros tendus je sais pas
si vous l'avez vu mais en guadeloupe
pardon sur su ramener un souvenir d'où
il a profité d'un échange avec les
journalistes ah oui on n'est pas dans la
raréfaction de la parole mais quand même
ces derniers mois il avait quand même un
petit peu tendance à éviter ce genre de
face à face parce que ça les énerve un
peu emmanuel macron à l'intermédiation
journalistique et l'a finalement il
prend toutes les occasions qui passe
parce qu'il a tout à fait raison
d'occuper encore une fois chaque espace
qui se présente à lui sur sur seulles
équilibre droite gauche là que convient
de voir comment vous le c'est assez
c'est assez constant en fait il a il a
réussi à saborder totalement la gauche à
son arrivée à l'elysée et puis
immédiatement après il s'est employé à
mettre en pièces la droite en débauchant
un premier ministre de droite en faisant
venir des figures de la droite n'était
pas le premier s'est passé pas lui qui a
inventé saint nicolas sarkozy l'avait
fait avant lui françois mitterrand
l'avait fait aussi auparavant et la
technique a fonctionné jusqu'ici
jusqu'ici parce que on a eu aussi et je
crois que vous aviez raison de le
souligner l'épisode qu'ovide il a
retourné l'opinion publique sur la crise
sanitaire pourrait quand même se
souvenir qu'au départ le signer dexia
oui le sentiment des français est
extrêmement critique il nous disait ni
plus ni moins leers on remonte dans le
temps quand le président prend la parole
et annonce le confinement c'est un
soutien total tout le monde est derrière
lui et dans les quinze jours qui suivent
retournement de l'opinion publique en
disant on nous a menti sur les masques
les français continuent de penser se
disent je crois qu'ils ont au moins 30 %
de taux de confiance excellent la
politique du gouvernement pour sortir de
la crise s'est effondré et sur le
jugement sur la crise sanitaire on l'a
testé de manière barreaux mais très
régulièrement on voyait que le jugement
était à cause de cette polémique sur les
masques à cause d'eux sur les vaccins
est allée à reculons sur la vaccination
donc il a accumulé les erreurs voir les
fautes politiques pendant toute une
période sauf que vous avez raison à la
fin et bien finalement on a un pays où
il ya un niveau de vaccination qui est
élevé ou des u11 niveau de protection
dont les gens lui sont reconnaissants
oui il s'agit encore là avec d'autres
pays à l'étranger par mangal mais on se
dit que finalement on s'en va il n'y a
pas de paix idéal
non c'est plutôt pas mal et puis peut
être aussi cette idée que kitty aurait
fait mieux parmi les les candidats
les mêmes sans aller jusqu'à qui aurait
fait mieux le simple bilan sur lui a
changé il a changé radicalement et ça
lui a permis de redorer son blason à
gauche parce que avant la crise
sanitaire il était le traître il était
le président des riches il était le
président de droite ça reste encore le
couac il aura de quoi qu'ils ont
sall a servi à gauche mais avec une
nuance justement sur le quoi qu'il en
coûte
qui n'arrive pas à se stopper et donc on
voit bien monter quand même tout le
débat et qui sera normalement pendant la
campagne présidentielle quand on sera
vraiment rentrés début 2022 sur la table
et ça c'était de voir philippe qui a été
d'ailleurs celui-ci voulait celui qui a
été vraiment avec l'ordre dans les
comptes qui est d'ailleurs une formule
qui est beaucoup reprises pendant les
débats élèves et pas seulement sur les
électeurs de droite très honnêtement
mais alors sur l'ensemble des français
comme haramboure swi des trompes landes
et bastien sont accrus cyrus tumeur la
droite c'est très important vous dit
edouard philippe n'est pas seulement le
sénat à majorité de droite majorité a
l'air vient de rejeter le budget c'est
l'une des informations importantes du
jour et bruno retailleau qui est chef de
file de la majorité hier au sénat deux
revendiquent un acte politique est ce
que ça veut dire parce que là je me
projette est ce que ça veut dire que ça
peut être un axe de campagne pour le
futur candidat allait à l'orthodoxie
budgétaire os 4 cylindres oui
c'est un axe de campagne peut-être mais
ça peut être alors ça peut être un
esprit par le politique pascal edwards
philippe a commencé dans son livre
franchement le candidat il peut prendre
le lead edouard philippe dage il a tout
- ou qu'il le prend il va en campagne
très bien je juste je mets un bémol sur
l'efficacité en termes d'impact sur
l'opinion publique est ce que les
français oui ou non alors alors non ça
dépend de comment rembourser la dette je
ne sais pas alors sur l'opinion publique
je vous suivrai mais en revanche avant
de se projeter plus largement ce qui
compte aussi ce sont les militants et
l'air or on sait très bien qu'il ya une
partie des militants ait l'air ils ne
savent plus où il habite aujourd'hui
dont une partie qui se dit est-ce que je
revote à nouveau pour pour emmanuel
macron et pour cette partie là je pense
qu'un des sujets majeurs qui fait que
vous allez porter votre vote sur
emmanuel macron ou sur le candidat et
leers et notamment la question de
l'ordre dans les comptes bon c'est que
c'est quelque chose qui résonne ce n'est
pas par hasard à chaque débat qu'il y a
eu aujourd'hui sur
pour la campagne et l'air on voit bien
que ce sont des thématiques qu'on était
qui ont été portés parce que ce sont
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il y a alors
pour l'instant c'est vrai que les
chiffres sont bons mais
mais mais on souffre dans le milieu des
entreprises quand même donc il ya quand
même un moment aussi où la réalité
risque de raz toiser est prêt souffre
alors elle souffre déjà pour récupérer
pour arriver à trouver du personnel
parce que vous avez un changement
complet de deux
prismes et de choix de vie allait parler
au tourisme à l'hôtellerie aux
restaurateurs aux changements de vie où
on ne sait plus comment arriver
c'est pas le débat suis remise sur les
entreprises françaises genre je reprends
la mapar dont je rêvais entendre pablo
pino vivien sûr sur cette question du
roger finalement par les sénateurs aient
l'air il parle d'un budget de campagne
électorale non c'est vraiment un acte
politique qui est revendiquée je pense
qu'ils ont relativement raison en tout
cas c'est leur opinion moi je pense que
là où emmanuel macron est sur un fil
mais en fait il est sur un fil depuis le
début de son exercice du pouvoir depuis
qu'il exerce le pouvoir c'est que il ya
une espèce de versatilité sur est-ce
qu'il est le candidat effectivement de
l'ordre budgétaire ou est-ce qu'il est
le candidat du néolibéralisme et en fait
on sait pas trop il joue entre les
faillis joue un peu sur les deux
tableaux c'est à dire que à la fois il
est pour un état fort parce que il l'a
prouvé pendant pendant le coït il a
dépensé énormément il est pour un état
fort d'ailleurs sur d'autres questions
sur les questions dites régaliennes qui
sont relatifs à la police etc et en même
temps il est tout le temps aux côtés
enfin il se veut tout le temps aux côtés
des entreprises il se veut du côté de
l'initiative entrepreneuriale etc et
c'est vrai que de ce point de vue là ils
essayent aussi d'ouvrir aux entreprises
un chant notamment en libéralisant le
monde du travail il l'avait déjà
commencé en tant que ministre de
l'économie sous françois hollande ils
essaient de libéraliser le monde du
travail deux cas c'est finalement ce
qu'ils faisaient est ce qu un des socles
aujourd'hui de la protection sociale
c'est à dire le code du travail pour
permettre dans sa tête aux entreprises
de d'embaucher plus facilement d'avoir
des règles plus souples et c'est donc là
du tout
oui oui exactement ce que je dis il a
commencé il a commencé avant mais on
sait que c'est beaucoup ce travail non
non on sait que ça a beaucoup été son
oeuvre aussi la loi elle comme riz à
emmanuel macron donc je pense qu'il est
il est sur un espèce de file comme ça et
en fait c'est un c'est un fil du rasoir
que les français aiment bien c'est à
dire que à la fois ils aiment bien qu'on
leur dise allez maintenant vous confiné
allez maintenant vous avez un pass and
it erp etc et en même temps on va quand
même un peu diminué le nombre de règles
on va assouplir les règles du droit du
travail etc je pense que cette crête
elle est compliqué à tenir mais s'ils
arrivent à la tenir jusqu'à avril 2022
s'il arrive à être crédibles sur cette
crête là je pense qu'il a un boulevard
devant lui alors s'il faut quand même
dire vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure
il allait si mal mais c'est pas parce
que 44% des français répondent oui à la
question et keane à mon président que ça
va faire 44 sur 100 que tout français
qui vont ils pas forcément
le 14 avril pour le premier tour c'est
une évidence mais il faut le rappeler
qu'une évidence vous avez raison de le
rappeler aujourd'hui dans les intentions
de vote à l'instar de ce qu'on me juge
sur le baromètre politique il est très
bien placé il est autour des 25% et
alors vous voyez des fluctuations des
candidats évidemment on n'est pas du
tout les pronostics à 7 à cette distance
d'une échéance électorale mais lui il
est remarquablement stable il a son
socle soit ils arrivent zemmour
montebourg baisse il fait à peu près le
même score ça bouge pas beaucoup alors
est ce que c'est un socle en tout cas
c'est à c'est un niveau auquel il se
maintient bien mais emmanuel matheron
macron son problème c'est qu'il n'a pas
de socle historique il vient de la
gauche il a récupéré une partie des voix
de la gauche il a été élu avec les voix
de la gauche et il a récupéré une partie
des voix de la droite donc je crois que
c'est ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
vous avez tout à fait raison il ya plein
d'écueils possible pour lui la route est
droite la pente est raide disait jean
pierre raffarin là en l'occurrence la
raideur de la pente elle va tenir à des
événements exogènes les conflits des
crises vous évoquez la guadeloupe dont
il peut en arriver plein d'ici dans les
cinq mois so lu ment
faire un autre président putatif
françois fillon s'est complètement
fracassé sur les affaires en janvier
donc on n'y est pas encore et puis il ya
autre chose il ya ce qui peut se passer
à droite là si une fois que le candidat
ait l'air sera investi quel qu'il soit
quel que soit celui on va dire des trois
favoris qui se qui se détachera on sait
pas ce qui peut se passer il peut il
peut gagner 3 4 points d'intentions de
vote eric zemmour peut en perdre aussi
marine le pen aussi et le ticket
d'entrée à 18% pour le second tour eh
bien ça ne
garantit pas emmanuel macron d'affronter
un candidat d'extrême droite quel qu'il
soit et autant face à marine le pen où
il faisait mon faudrait vraiment une
catastrophe pour ne pas passer autant
face à l'un des trois favoris de la
droite quand s'est testé dans les
sondages c'est plutôt autour de 50 50
donc c'est assez compliqué quand même
donc encore évidemment beaucoup
d'inconnues et on reste très prudents et
les choses de le dire à cinq mois du
d'un premier tour on va passer au focus
d'actualité 2
de votre de notre baromètre puisqu'on
est partenaire sur sur ce baromètre
chaque mois le duel d'image entre marine
le pen et eric zemmour et je mens dastic
jourdain qui doit pas être très loin de
nous rejoindre
on voit s'en va détailler bonsoir si on
va détailler évidemment ce duel d'image
d'abord au sujet d'eric zemmour oui ils
perdent du terrain régime ont clairement
ils perdent du terrain dans les
intentions de vente et donc par rapport
vous l'avais dit à marine le pen
clairement sa campagne patine ces jours
ci ça se traduit par un recul de
plusieurs points dans les intentions de
22,2 points l'écart se creuse à nouveau
en faveur de marine le pen 18%
d'intentions de vote contre
14% pour le polémiste plus inquiétant
pour exercer cette mauvaise image que
les français ont de lui eric zemmour est
tout simplement tout simplement thomas
la personnalité la plus rejeter de
l'histoire j'ai ce que j'ai lu un visuel
du baromètre avec 61% de détestation
clairement eric zemmour président ça ne
passe pas toujours selon ce sondage
l'image d'eric zemmour est assez
catastrophique il faut lire entre les
deux tiers et les trois quarts des
français estiment qu'il est d'extrême
droite agressif raciste on va le voir à
l'écran misogyne et puis surtout
dangereux en résumé pour eric zemmour
c'est un effondrement total dans
l'opinion quelques petites semaines 66
ans 68% des français le jugent
incompétent définitifs tôt mal les
français comme les sympathisants du
rassemblement national et des
républicains considèrent que marine le
pen est davantage capable de gagner la
présidentielle kirghize et moi que et
bien la finaliste de 2017 est à même est
plus à même de diriger la france bref
marine le pen dira peut-être dans
quelques temps merci à eric zemmour dans
quelques mois merci d'avoir contribué à
la recentrer un peu dans l'opinion
publique merci steve alors justement
laetitia c'est le thème de de votre oeil
ça s'enchaîne très bien on l'a dit c'est
d'enchaîner les deux cas il ne creuse
oui c'est sympa et oui vous qui vous
passe le ballon de rugby comme comme un
français sur le black bresse le
processus de normalisation
en fait j'ai été d'accord avec vous gaël
qui oui c'est un peu ce que vous avez
dit il a resservi à adoucir un peu
l'image de marine le pen et c'est ce que
dit steve et plus j'avance alors je vous
fais part de ma progression de penser
oui plus je me dis que non qu'en fait
c'est une erreur de penser cela c'est il
me semble que au contraire il a permis à
marine le pen de normaliser sa
radicalité c'est à dire que il a est là
il a permis de normaliser des prises de
position qui aurait été impossible avant
l'été et ça c'est assez simple de le
prouver c'est à dire que elle arrive en
septembre avec un nouveau slogan
nouvelle affiche liberté liberté chérie
évidemment des paroles qui sont
empruntés à la marseillaise avec tout
sourire fond vert et regarde vers le
haut il n'y a pas de marine le pen ya
pas de sigle de logo du parti et en
novembre changement complètement de cap
parce que eric zemmour montant et la
nouvelle affiche où on va voir c'est
rendre aux français leur pays alors
l'argent aux français leur argent donc
c'est pouvoir d'achat immigration
d'accord est-ce que je pose la question
en fait est ce que ces slogans rendre
aux français leur pays aurait était
possible et bénéfique pour marine le pen
avant l'été je ne crois pas et ça est ce
que ça leur renvoie aussi à ce que
faisait son père auparavant oui puisque
en 1981 le slogan de jean marie lebel
c'était la france et les français
d'abord voilà la france et les français
d'abord et lui même avaient commencé en
2002 le processus de dédiabolisation
parce qu'il disait j'ai retrouvé une
phrase il disait socialement je suis de
gauche économiquement de droite
nationalement je suis de france très
honnêtement on pourra mettre cette
phrase dans la bouche d'eric zemmour et
marine le pen ça passerait crème comme
on dit aujourd'hui eric zemmour en fait
a servi aussi à décomplexer cette droite
qui est à la droite de la droite qu'on
appelle droite hors les murs souvent et
vous allez remarquer que dans tous les
débats tous les candidats à
l'investiture et l'air ont repris le
terme et donc la théorie du grand
remplacement en disant non quand ils
disent non non mais c'est à dire non moi
je ne reprends pas cette théorie mais je
la cite quand même au passage mais quand
même dans le fond c'est vrai que quand
on regarde le contexte c'est pas s'il
faut vous voyez et ça il me semble qu'il
ya six mois c'était impossible donc eric
zemmour a radicalisé le camp de droite
lr alors l'extrême est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette analyse a laissé
agir je crois que eric zemmour a
effectivement libérer une parole de
façon exponentielle fulgurante donc
aujourd'hui on est sur des thématiques
qui n'aurait jamais été possible de
mettre sur la table de façon aussi
récurrente aussi quotidiennes par malizé
et normalisé donc en cela contenu des
débats et leur pardon nous interrompre
d'aujourd'hui il aurait peut-être
choquer
je crois qu'eric zemmour oui a rendu a
mis à l'agenda des questions qui était
dans toutes les têtes mais qui n'était
pas possible d'aborder jusque là moi je
rajouterais également en quelque chose
qui me frappe qui est qu en fait dans la
différence avec marine le pen on a
l'impression que la radicalité
totalement extrême et parfois non
maîtrisée on a l'impression de d'eric
zemmour
arrive à faire passer aussi marine le
pen sur trois thématiques ou avant
c'était des choses qui étaient quand
même compliquées pour elle dans la
perception politique c'est un la
compétence parce qu'il y avait quand
même la question du débat plus que ratée
du 2e tour la question de l'expérience
politique où on avait vraiment
l'impression que la haye
lala envie de ré existé et elle reprend
un terrain politique avec beaucoup
beaucoup de savoir faire on peut ne pas
partager ses idées mais en tout cas elle
a été capable de redresser la barre elle
a pris conscience de ce qui se passait
et donc avec une agilité politiques qui
n'étaient pas forcément les premiers
adjectif ou les premiers qualificatifs
que l'on avait je parle sous votre
contrôle gaël mais quand on parlait de
de marine le pen on parlait de démagogie
on parlait parfois de populisme de
racisme mais il n'y avait pas est donc
arrivé finalement par sa propre
radicalité à faire passer marine le pen
pour un vote qui serait quasiment
presque classique dans sa radicalité
c'est en soi déjà un x vous redonne la
parole dans un instant mais je vais vous
entendre pablo pino vivien sur la
stratégie de marine le pen effectivement
est-ce qu'il a pas tout simplement fait
son effet fait preuve de sens ou de
justesse politique elle aurait pu courir
après ou sur enchérit derrière eric
zemmour en le voyant grimper dans les
sondages mais elle est là pas besoin
elle avait comme depuis qu'elle a pris
le pouvoir au front national qui est
devenu le rassemblement national elle
cherche à dédiaboliser son parti donc là
c'était juste une occasion de plus pour
continuer cette oeuvre de
dédiabolisation et moi je trouve que ce
matin je lui ai encore entendu elle
était invitée dans une dans une matinale
et elle tenait des propos à chaque fois
qu'on lui parle de zemmour moi je trouve
que c'est ces réponses sont absolument
fantastiques je l'avais entendu parler
de zemmour ya il ya trois semaines on
dit mais qu'est ce que vous pensez
d'eric zemmour est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec lui comment vous
positionnez elle dit non non moi j'ai
promis de parler de ça moi j'ai envie de
parler de l'assurance chômage de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui va
appauvrir des millions de gens et là ce
matin on leur pose la question à dix
mais eric zemmour il veut fracturée moi
je veux réunir les français et du coup
elle elle apparaît comme étant une
personnalité très sympathique voire
consensuelle ce qui est quand même quand
c'est la base de ce que c'est que le
ratio leur assemblée nationale et le
front national c'est exceptionnel auprès
matic mais elle y arrive après match on
va écouter marc emery taisne et je vous
redonne la parole juste après elle se
plaignait d'être attaqués aussi ça dans
sa déclaration
il note ça finit par être suspect tout
de même cette volonté de n'attaquer que
moi car en réalité ils n'attaquent
jamais emmanuel macron d'ici dont on
peut non jamais si l'attaqué maniema
compte dans ses décisions encore revenir
sur la guadeloupe il a trés oui enfin
très rarement et toujours avec des mots
qui sont extrêmement pesé rien à voir
avec la violence dont il fait preuve à
mon égard
marine le pen cible des attaques d'eric
zemmour max mais mais je pense qu'elle a
relativement raison après je pense qu'il
faut aussi voir le prés mais moore en
fait ils dépassent la stricte extrême
droite je pense que il ya vraiment aussi
un problème chez elle est enfin moi j'ai
écouté les débats et l'air c'est quand
même la course à l'échalote derrière le
la radicalité sur toutes les questions
il ne parle que d'immigration que
d'immigration un peu d'islam et puis à
nouveau sur l'immigration c'est
absolument fou avait un thème comme et
la sécurité vous avez un type comme
michel barnier j'ai relu ce qu'il disait
au moment où wauquiez était le patron
des républicains
ce que ce qu'ils disaient c'est un homme
et wauquiez c'est un populiste je ne
veux pas de ça je n'ai rien à voir avec
ce type est aujourd'hui mais il tient
exactement les mêmes propos que que
laurent wauquiez donc il ya vraiment il
ya eu un déplacement en fait de ce que
de ce qu'étaient les l air et qui
pouvaient la modération chez les leurs
pour moi était représenté par un type
comme michel barnier aujourd'hui c'est à
youtube a donné un ultimatum les
candidats pardon l'hexagone oui non mais
vous vous adonnez en fait je suis très
étonnée et je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
français et même des sympathisants l air
ou anciennement ump qui sont étonnés en
fait par cette lente enfin non en fait
cette rapide dérives de ce qu'était la
droite traditionnelle la droite
conservatrice où une partie aussi la
droite libérale ce qui est bien et c'est
pas du tout anecdotique c'est que marine
le pen a retrouvé son essence première
c'est à dire que maintenant elle met sa
féminité en avant je n'ai jamais entendu
cet argument dans la bouche de marine le
pen jusqu'à maintenant et c'est vrai
qu'elle est une femme c'est pas anodin
je suis désolé quand on se présente à
l'élection présidentielle et donc c'est
la première fois que je l'entends dire
ça depuis quelques semaines un stère
elle a compris que eric zemmour était
taxé de misogynie et qu'il a produit des
livres des ouvrages donc on peut
retrouver les traces de sa pensée et
donc elles sortent sur cette idée là
pourquoi pas gaël sliman yahia vous
pouvez revenir dessus même si steve en a
parlé cette détestation quand même
effectivement majeur historique vous
employer ce terme là oui alors on a
testé des personnalités qui étaient des
championnes du rejet la particularité
sur le baromètre politique koné s'est
plaint de baromètre politique existe
depuis très longtemps en général on
teste des bonnes opinions mauvaise
opinion du tas là on est sur une cote
d'adhésion donc ce qu'on mesure en
adhésion c'est assez fort ça poutre ceux
transférés en partie en votes
personnalité qu'on soutient qu'on estime
et puis il ya l'indifférence ce qu'il
faut bien le savoir la plupart des
français à l'égard de la plupart des
personnes âgées politique sur son nid
dans le rejet absolu ni dans l'adhésion
et puis il ya le rejet et quand on
atteint quand on approche des 50% de
rejet on est dans des zones très rouge
très dangereuse jean marie le pen qui
était le champion du rejet pouvait
atteindre les 55 56 % de rejet au plus
fort de ses saillies
marine le pen était la championne du
rejet sur votre palmarès du rejet
pendant très longtemps alors on a eu des
pics de jean luc mélenchon quand il
disait la république et moi il ya encore
au à une entrée ou les traits ou jean
luc mélenchon mais eric zemmour avec ses
61 % c'est quelque chose de très
important à grave oui ça s'aggrave c'est
ça s'aggrave il y là il a gagné si j'ose
dire trop quatre points j'ai plus de
mémoire mais sur le rejet tout en
gagnant pas de points sur l'adhésion
pour comparer les deux il ya douze
points de rejet de plus sur eric zemmour
que sur marine le pen et ça c'est sûr
est-ce que c'est une sorte de vote utile
de marine le pen ou
agressive de détestation alors c'est
surtout c'est surtout que derrière
de l'intention de vote c'est ce que
j'avais dit sur ce plateau avec avec
vous il ya quelques il ya quelques mois
envoyés dans les sondages eric zemmour
montait dans les intentions de vote mais
déjà je tirait la sonnette d'alarmé pour
lui sur ces éléments plus qualitatif
sert qu'on peut réunir on peut avoir dix
pour cent des gens qui vous adore et 90
qui vous détestent et vous arriverez à
10 % dans les intentions de vote et vous
vous direz formidable je vais monter
jusqu'au ciel sauf que ça c'est une
vraie limite et la multiplicité de ses
interventions sur tout un tas de sujets
qui ont choqué les gens
sur je reviendrai pas sur ce qui est dit
sur le bataclan mais il tout un tas de
propos qui ont choqué y compris un
électorat très dur à battre
serveur la bascule elle se fait alors
vous avez évoqué nos partenaires de
mascaret mascaret c'est le nouveau nom
de dentsu consulting et ce sont nos
partenaires qui suivent ce qui se dit
sur les réseaux sociaux ce que nous on
est sur du sondage et les réseaux
sociaux c'est intéressant à suivre aussi
et sur les réseaux sociaux ce
qu'observait mascaret le mois dernier
c'est qu'eric zemmour écrasé tour ne
parler que de lui que parfois souvent en
mal mais enfin il occupait tout l'espace
il était devant maquereau en présence en
visibilité quantitatives sur les réseaux
là ce mois ci il est moins présent
toujours avec des polémiques et puis les
autres émergent marine le pen fait
parler d'elle emmanuel macron on l'a
évoqué et donc moi ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est ce que vous avez dit
les uns et les autres je reviendrai pas
longuement là dessus c'est cette
histoire d'adoucissement de l'image de
marine le pen alors tout est relatif
vous avez tout à fait raison marine le
pen garde de toute façon une mauvaise
image dans l'opinion pas s'y tromper un
effet un effet comparatif favorable avec
eric zemmour mais en réalité elle a une
mauvaise image mais son image s'améliore
tous ces traits d'image négative
s'améliore par exemple marine le pen est
encore jugée raciste par les français
mais ce n'est que par 60% de nos
concitoyens c'est déjà beaucoup me direz
vous mais par rapport à eric zemmour
c'est rien quand on compare les deux il
est jugé bien plus raciste bien plus
dangereux et donc moi je vois un double
bénéfice si zemmour ne reprend pas un
second souffle et ne repasse pas devant
marine le pen il y aurait eu un double
bénéfice à la présence d'eric zemmour 1
ça aura permis d'adoucir son image et
vous arrivez raison sans qu elle même
née du besoin d'adoucir son projet et
son programme analyse et sa radicalité
en quelques c'est très bien dit voilà ça
permet ça et le deuxième élément c'est
que quand même à eux deux avec dupont
aignan ça fait trente-cinq pour cent des
intentions de vote elle se retrouverait
avec des réserves de voix que jamais le
front national nous sommes au delà des
constats conséquence de de cet
essoufflement dans l'est dans les
intentions de vote pourrait aisément on
rappelle qu'il ya une marge d'erreur on
rappelle qu'on est à cinq mois depuis
son élection présidentielle bref j'aime
bien le dire quand même à chaque fois
qu'on vous avez raison d'utiliser les
sondages où les enquêtes d'opinion en
termes de stratégie alexia germond
est-ce que vous pensez que ça oblige
eric zemmour a accéléré une éventuelle
entrée en campagne oui d'ailleurs quand
on a appris qu'il avait réservé les
zénith le 5 décembre comme par hasard le
lendemain du jour où on aura le le
candidat ait l'air et le même jour que
jean luc mélenchon et le même jour que
jean luc mélenchon tout à fait vous avez
raison ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'on peut on peut se dire que
raisonnablement il y aura peut-être une
une annonce sur la candidature en amont
parce qu'on voit mal faire une annonce
de candidature
au zénith parce que je crois qu'il faut
quand même qu'il ya un ancrage et comme
déjà il souffre d'un manque d'ancrage
politique il faut pas que ça se fasse
dans une salle de spectacle on va dire
donc pour lui oui il ya une nécessité
d'accélérer ça c'est clair mais il ya
aussi une nécessité de se maîtriser
parce que je crois que c'est surtout ça
que le mois de novembre nous a montré
moi je me souviens d'avoir eu le plaisir
d'être là en octobre pour voir le
sondage également d'octobre on voyait
bien déjà alors que l'analyse était plus
compliqué puisqu'il était entendu en
hausse des intentions de vote donc nous
étions à rebours avec votre sondage qui
montrait déjà la capacité de rôle j'ai
traîné derrière la limite de phrases
chocs oui oui parce que je crois qu'il
ya un moment où comme vous êtes en
dérapage incontrôlé même ceux qui aiment
la radicalité se retrouvent choqué pas
tant sur le fond mais parfois sur la
forme d'accord mais on va pâtir et non
plus des leçons définitives parce que il
y a deux options effectivement soit ben
c'était son plafond de verre il va
peut-être devenir un petit candidat sous
la barre des 10% un destin à la
chevènement choix qui était monté
jusqu'à 14% en janvier celle versée le
union autour de 5 c'est le risque c'est
la visée par trois son score exactement
comme chevènement c'est un vrai risque
possible ça mais
je peux aussi repartir
al haouz pablo pino bibi je pense que
l'erreur en fait c'est de considérer que
le rôle où la fonction de eric zemmour
dans le champ politique c'est d'accéder
à la présidence de la république c'est
pas sa fonction aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
il est un trublion et effectivement il
ya un effet d'optique comme la barre
d'entrée au deuxième tour est autour et
en dessous de 20% on a l'impression que
si on a l'impression que voilà il n'est
pas très loin d'être second tour
médiation au second tour il est de
toutes les façons la mine et peu importe
le candidat il est très en dessous de à
la free money de macron marine le pen du
camp ndlr ou n'importe quel candidat de
la gauche donc aujourd'hui sa fonction
c'est de déportés touchant politique
vers la droite s'était ouvert l'extrême
droite tout genre avec des propositions
qui sont qui sont choc mais c'est même
pas je pense qu'il n'a pas vocation à se
présidentialiser il n'a pas vocation à
calmer le rythme de ces petites phrases
chocs au contraire au contraire je pense
que il va il va en rajouter on lui ont
fait que lui tendent des micros à chaque
fois il ya des aréopages de journalistes
autour de lui à la moindre de ses
sorties je pense que ça va continuer et
ça y est paradoxalement alors même que
dans les intentions de vote ça va
pouvoir se tasser va peut-être se tasser
je pense que lui va y voir au contraire
une possibilité d'exprimer encore plus
avant ce qu'il pense sur à peu près tous
les sujets liés surtout à l'immigration
la sécurité et l'islam un renoncement
d'eric zemmour personnes y croient
autour de la table non moi je vais je
pense au contraire à un rebond je pense
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
et je pense qu'on se trompe quand on
enterre là aujourd'hui on est pris dans
un trou d'air moi je pense aux comptes à
qui un robot et vous avez tout à fait
raison il a toujours dit qu'il était
dans une bataille idéologique alors
gramsci et effectivement il est en train
de l'amener et il est plutôt
très en avance dans cette bataille il me
semble pas de renoncements vous y croyez
pas non non pas de renoncement je serai
pas de pronostics surtout qu'on renonce
man ou pas j'ai juste un petit point de
désaccord je suis d'accord sur le sur
l'idée qu'ils ne cherchent pas être
président de la république bien sûr mais
il a quand même un objectif il a vous
avez forcément quand il être président
non je pense pas qu'il y en aurait une
fracture revanche en revanche journée je
rejoins ce que veut autour de vous qui
n'ont méprisés non mais ce que vous
disiez sur gramsci et donc c'est la
victoire idéologique qui lui importe
pour préparer le rêve de patrick buisson
de l'union des droites descendent de la
deûle de jallet à droite et donc
pourquoi pas la préparer à autre chose
or pour ça il est je pense qu'il
souhaiterait quand même passer devant
marine le pen pour pour tenter avec
légitime oui pour cela rendez marie le
pen un appareil politique darel ce qu'il
n'a pas et c'est quand même très
important d'appareils politiques avec de
la présence sur tout le territoire mais
marion maréchal dalaba d'appareils
aujourd'hui ils ont essayé les prendre
il faut quand
même les électeurs de droite
conservatrice traditionnelle et
républicaine qui vont se retrouver
orphelins au milieu de tout ça parce
qu'une fois que vous avez
potentiellement cette union des droites
qui est fait c'est de ce point de vue là
que ce sera intéressant d'analyser ce
qui se passe avec horizon le parti des
douars film parce que pour un certain
nombre de d'électeurs de droite que le
mieux c'est la ligne voilà
puisqu'il y est ça la connaît pas pour
ça il va falloir attendre le 4 décembre
lr évidemment ça rebattra forcément les
cartes merci beaucoup à tous d'avoir
participé à ce premier débat de sens
public notre émission continue
évidemment on ne ratez pas